dr nash in total transformation who is
sponsoring this segment have helped so
many clients with weight loss and much
more take a look
working with dr nash i lost 70 pounds in
three and a half months and reversed my
type 2 diabetes and i feel great dr nash
dominic his results are amazing 70
pounds you reverses type 2 diabetes tell
us more tell us how you did it dominic
found out he was pre-diabetic when he
was only 20 years old trying to figure
it out on his own by the time he's 25 he
hits full blown type 2 diabetes he
didn't want to manage it he wanted to
reverse it and that's why he came to us
because that is what we help people do
so how do you reverse type 2 diabetes
so the key to reversing conditions that
are metabolic in nature whether that's
fatty liver type 2 diabetes or certain
kinds of heart disease is by going after
the root factors that cause cause them
so a lot of times people think if they
simply eat less and move more that
that's going to be enough to turn these
conditions around and it really isn't
knowing the type of food when to eat it
how to eat it and what kind of nutrition
needs to be supplemented in there to
accelerate the change that's the key to
the weight loss and then there's a whole
different protocol to teach the body to
hold it
is that why other doctors are just
managing these symptoms which is fine
they're managing things but you're
making a change for your clients right
so most doctors are kind of stuck in a
poor position because they don't really
have a lot of time with their patients
to teach them about the importance of
reversing it so they've just got to try
to do their best at the time to keep the
patient as healthy as possible and
that's why they use medication the best
it's going to do is manage your
condition which means for the
overwhelming majority you're going to
stay overweight and you're going to
continue to get sicker the results are
amazing with your clients your patients
and the results with you as well let's
talk about you for a second because you
you look beautiful 80 pounds over 12
years ago you've kept the weight off how
do you do it yeah so same thing i was
one of those people that were in those
cycles i struggled with obesity for 25
years i did 36 different types of diets
trying to figure out how to lose it and
it wasn't until i started investing
investigating it from my medical
knowledge that i found out about these
underlying issues that literally
sabotage you even when you're eating
less and moving more once i dialed in on
those issues and went after them that's
when i saw the 80 pound weight loss and
that's when it stayed off
so many success stories with you dr nash
are these results typical with your
client they are typical with my clients
if my clients do what i say when we're
dealing with metabolic damage you really
can't sort of halfway do it you can't
phone it in you do have to be focused
but the rewards are well worth it not
only getting the body back to its normal
weight and holding it but reversing
life-threatening diseases like type 2
diabetes amazing dr nash is your coach
you just got to follow her playbook
every week you bring a special dr nash
what do you have for us today i do so
normally when people want to do the
online evaluation with me that is
typically 97 because it takes a good
hour of my time alone online with you to
talk about it instead when people say
that they saw me on las vegas now with
jc of course i'm going to do something
like 10 spots available for less than 10
dollars and taking advantage of it that
way also gets you a special price on the
program if you work for me as well so
really going online and getting it
scheduled now would be your best bet
give yourself that kind of gift for the
holidays
once again thank you to total
transformation for sponsoring this
segment and don't forget to visit
drnash.com
forward slash eval to take advantage of
her special offer